welcome back to the David Pakman show I
am of course not David Pakman I am
Benjamin Dixon hosted the podcast the
sensational podcast if I must say so
myself the Benjamin Nixon show you
should go check it out David would be
back tomorrow so you know those of you
who missed them you'll be fine he'll be
back he'll be back tomorrow you know if
you use Amazon it's hard not to because
of how ubiquitous it is everything that
you ever need that you can't find
somewhere else you can find on Amazon
but it really is getting to a point
where that convenience that we all enjoy
from it from Amazon is coming at a cost
that should be too high right the item
may be cheap but the real cost of it in
terms of human life and the treatment of
their employees is obscenely high
there's a study that comes out that
reveals Guardian calm did an
investigation it reveals a pattern of
Amazon refusing to file employees
workers compensation and cutting off pay
lead leave unexpectedly and then
pressuring employees to sign statements
that they will not they would not
discuss this issue they would not say
anything negative or derogatory about
Amazon in order to get paid I mean it's
it's a it's like extortion and but to
keep you quiet about talking about the
conditions that you're working under so
this is what the Guardian had to say I
want to pull up their quote on the
screen for you now a guardian
investigation has revealed numerous
cases of Amazon workers suffering from
workplace accidents or injuries in its
gigantic warehouse system and being
treated in ways that leave them homeless
unable to work or bereft of income the
next quote says the following over the
course of a few weeks
Amazon medical triage area gave her
being the the individual who was studied
in this investigation
use of a heating pad to use on her back
while Amazon management sent her a home
each day without pay until the
individual pushed for workers
compensation and it gives you the story
of of a woman who's 49 years old who
injured herself on the job and
while she was on the job she attempted
to continue working with this injury but
because she could not perform as quickly
and as efficiently as she did without
the injury management begins sending her
home so let me set the stage for you
again and then I want to go back to that
second quote after I set the stage
because the second quote is better in
context of what's actually happening in
the story you have a 49 year old woman
who got injured on the job at Amazon
because of improper equipment they did
not have the right equipment in place in
their warehouse so she got injured
because of Amazon she continued to try
to work at Amazon but because she
couldn't keep up with the efficiency
goals of Amazon Amazon management sent
her home without work now let's pull up
that second tweet that second quote one
more time over the course of a few weeks
Amazon's medical triage area gave her
use of a heating pad to use on her back
while Amazon management sent her home
each day without pay until she pushed
for workers compensation let's go to the
third quote and to get the rest of the
story this is what the Guardian reported
she said I tried to work again but I
couldn't stretch my right arm out and
I'm right-handed so I was having a hard
time keeping up this went on for about
three weeks Alan said despite not
getting paid
Alan was spending her own money to drive
60 miles one way to the warehouse each
day just to be sent home and again she
was sent home because she could not keep
up with the efficiency standards of
Amazon because she was injured at Amazon
because of a faulty piece of equipment
that Amazon did not have installed
properly this is not just the first
story that we've heard about the obscene
things that are happening at these
Amazon warehouses the cost of that that
dollar cheaper
I don't know DVD if you're even buying
DVDs you get it for a dollar cheaper on
Amazon but now you see that that cost
has a real life cost and value
that is taken out of these employees
that work in these factories that that
are afraid to use the bathroom because
if they go and use the bathroom they'll
miss their efficiency standards and the
fact that they just don't make a livable
wage in the first place many of them are
having to resort to living off of our
safety nets because Amazon doesn't want
to pay what they're paying and and this
shows you it shows you that the Amazon
is is really in this of course they're
in this this is what for-profit
businesses do this is what this is very
similar to what made Walmart the giant
that it is Walmart didn't just become
this this this giant corporation that's
everywhere in this country simply
because they got lower prices they got
lower prices because they beat their
workers into submission because they
busted up any opportunity for unions to
gather in form at Walmart and it's it
cost real lives I mean the the the
standard of living the the ability to
have some autonomy and some dignity in
their work and people you know people
take these jobs because they have no
other choice but to take these jobs they
have to work for a living and so they
end up working at these sweatshops right
here in the United States of America by
the name of Walmart and by the name of
Amazon and all the while all the while
while it may take a few million dollars
to fix what's happening in any
particular warehouse you know that
individual warehouse you know Jeff Bezos
he's raking it in I want to bring up
this tweet on your screen so you so that
you can just get an idea the median
Amazon employees salary is $28,000 Jeff
Bezos makes that much in ten seconds I
mean the disparity is atrocious and yet
this is celebrated in this American
capitalistic system this is Jeff Bezos
is is championed as a great symbol of
American success but that success comes
directly as a result of draconian
policies instituted by his mid-level
management let me let me talk about
mid-level management for a second
because these are the people who
probably are making $50,000 a year and
and and because they're there
you know they came out of the you know
working-class 50,000 it's pretty closer
to working-class still I can attest to
that but but because they're making a
little bit of money now they are going
to be some of the hardest task masters
in this warehouse so people who
understand the working conditions of the
proletariat right now let's just use the
language right the people who understand
the real conditions are the very people
who are the happiest to carry out the
demands and the nd and the standards of
people like Jeff Bezos this doesn't work
Jeff Bezos does not become a billionaire
without some accomplices in this right
that the conditions in Amazon and
Walmart they don't happen just because
of the Walton family and because of
Bezos no they happen because you have a
lot of willing accomplices who feel it
is their duty to make sure that we carry
out the efficiency standards to the tea
because if we carry it out I can get a
bonus and because if I don't carry it
out there's a threat of me losing my job
meanwhile people making $28,000 a year
injuring themselves and can't even work
they're not even they're not even able
to make that $28,000 a year because
they're being sent home by managers who
say I know you were injured on your job
here I know that we haven't really given
you any means of fixing what we broke
we're not gonna give you some disability
we're not gonna give you any of that but
you need to go home because if you're
here trying to work for a living then
you're going to make us less efficient
and subsequently people are going
homeless because they can't make any
money that's that's the real price of
Amazon Prime